Yeah. I never thought about having kids, you know, I mean, but uh, years ago,
Al magical invited me to his house and I had dinner with his kids and his wife,
and it was proper.
We put the thing on the thing and then the utensils that was nice candles,
you know what I mean? It was real nice. You cut things, you know what I mean?
And you're very proper, but you just,
you could see just the relationship with Al's kids are wonderful kids and him
and I thought, Hmm, maybe I want to have a baby, but I have it.
This is going to cook a go to you now, uh,
I saw you at a party once with your daughter and you were playing soccer with
her on a field. Right. And I, I'm sorry. I mean,
you just never, I never, never imagined you playing with children.
I'm glad you didn't the way you just put
it in terms of like.
It wasn't like you frolicking, you don't look,
you don't look like somebody that would frolic frolic or like, you know,
me being in a, you know, just, just in wheat, in wheat.
No, I'm just saying, you know what I mean? It says he brought it up,
he got uncomfortable. So he's trying to make me uncomfortable, uncomfortable.
Just, you know, we'd never see you, you know,
I mean with butterflies and running through a field, but right. But w I,
I was watching you and I, you know.
Were you on mushrooms when
I was just running in slow motion, I would just look at you.
And you had such, you love your daughter so much. You were playing and,
you know, I mean, she would slip and you would giggle and you were like,
and I thought to myself, I think I want a kid. You know what I mean?
Cause that just seems fun. And it seems like Bill's having fun. Fun,
right? It's it's, it's, it's a life-changer correct.
Yeah. And, and, and, and whatever you have, whoever the parent is,
that's the opposite sex. They get a little bit more because like, if,
cause it's like, if, if you guys have a daughter, right,
she's going to be the disciplinary and she's going to be seen through all your
daughter's go. And she's, she's totally manipulating you. Right. A blah.
And you're going to be a puddle of mush. Right. And then she's like, Oh my God,
I feel like the bad guy, but then you have a son and then it flips.
And then it's just like, you know, you know, you're going to be like, Oh my God,
my little man and blah, it'd be like that. Yeah.
And then you're going to be all like, yeah, let him do that to you.
He's one of those things. But like, no,
I'm all in with my, yeah. I know. I, you know, if you saw some of the,
like what.
Like paint, like you do pottery stuff.
And paint. Oh, I'm beyond like, what do you do? I can,
I can do her hair. I can like, I can do, I can French braid. I can do the whole,
I can get her. Cause I had this,
this horrible feeling that one day my wife wasn't going to be there.
And she was going to have to go to school with their hair,
not looking the way she wanted.
And I going to school every day with orange hair. What the that was like,
so I remember that. So I was just like, I'm gonna make sure that,
that you you're,
you're looking all right now I'm like totally into it's crazy because now,
like I see in like women, like in movies and stuff,
and I'm looking at their hair trying to figure it out.
[inaudible] yeah. I bet you, you didn't do this. I don't know.
I'm not at your house.
Um, do you watch programs with her? Like, like.
Hey listen, the best thing is, uh, I got she's into bugs bunny.
Oh wow. Classic. But you got to watch out.
Cause there is some old school bugs bunny.
They got a little bit of black face in there and they got a little bit of, uh,
we, we, we were, we were, you know,
at war with Japan. So there's some,
there's some war propaganda. It's kind of funny when they do it to the Germans.
Cause it's white on white, but the other way it gets a little crazy.
But if you stay with the mainstream ones, it's fine. And what's,
what's awesome. Is, uh, we got,
we got in an argument about bugs bunny is she's
convinced that Elmer Fudd, his name is doc. Cause he says what's up doc?
And I'm like, no, that's just what he said. His name's Elmer fudge phone. No,
his name is doc. I was going like, no it's Elmer Fudd.
And she got really upset. And so I just, all right, it's dark. It's dark.
So I have to wait until she's emotionally ready. What does that some of the, uh,
Japanese propaganda. Oh, Oh, that isn't bad. Yeah. It's classic.
No, no, no, no. There there's. There's worse than that. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
There's definitely, uh, I mean the eyes don't seem that slow.
That's not a good example. Yeah.
It's just every once in a while and there's like little subtle things, right.
The swans versus the ducks, ah, like that,
where it's real subtle and you just kind of set the gun. Like
I don't like it. Yeah. Then I just defer to my wife and she would look at me.
Do you want more or no? Oh man. I, I would, if I didn't start solely,
I would definitely have more. But um, I think we're good. We've got one of each.
Sweetie. I'm telling you right now. Okay. Let me just,
let me just say something. Okay. In front of bill. Yeah. In front of bill.
All right. I think I'm ready.
Wonderful. Okay. Congratulations.
Yeah. Okay. Okay. I'm a man of change. Okay.
I've changed a lot of things about myself. Okay. And I'm healing, you know,
a lot of the trauma stuff, all that stuff. I'm trying to heal it up.
I think I'm, let's just sorry. I think I, I think I please,
I think I can have one. All right. So just all right, good. Anyway,
at the end of the, okay. Just think about it.
At the end.
I just loved all of the body language in all of them. He's pointing that way.
He does this a lot. Like if he wasn't already,
I would probably have had six children by now. But because feel like he's.
Like six children in one human Panda. It's you know?
Yeah. I do do that. I gotta, you gotta,
you gotta like gotta tell me, well, you say you throw yourself into things.
Yeah. If you have a kid, you have to do that.
That's not something that you can kind of be into for a minute. Bill.
Uh, during our couples counseling, he was like, yeah, like if she's,
when she's pregnant, I'm just going to take more road dates.
And when the baby's born, it's a joke.
Joke in the couple of no, but if she, she, if she's pregnant,
like in the beginning, when you're fine and everything you can, yeah.
You got to stockpile the money. That's what I'm pushing for the
cut the nuts during the summer for the winter. No, it's a good move.
And then the two months after, you know, like the month before,
and then the two months after I'm there, you stay in town and then,
then you just do quick hits after that. Right. See, there we go.
And I don't care if you, you know, you get hit a night nurse. Yeah.
We're gonna get a night nurse, babe. Yes. Sell everything in this garage.
If you have night, Kevin Nealon said that what? Get a night nurse.
You have to take a second mortgage. Get a night. No, it's,
it's that whole idea of just doing it by yourself? Yes. Is,
is the, it's a, it's a long, no it's Butler thing. All right. Well
that it's, it's not like the old school.
That's the new school way that people tried for 30 years that failed
horrifically because everybody else it's just like, you know, um,